[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on peut apprécier l'économie on peut
aimer l'économie il ne suffit pas
d'aimer pour bien la décrypter
[Musique]
oui cette inflation un impact sur le
panier de la ménagère et sur le coup de
vie en général
par exemple je suis pas supermarché on
va plutôt du dans les rayons directs
avec la liste de courses ce qui évite de
d'être tenté par des choses
superficielles
je pense qu'il faudrait peut-être que
les gens et apprennent à vivre d'une
manière différente surtout ça je crois
qu'il faut qu'il faut changer ses
habitudes moi j'ai arrêté de prendre ma
voiture par exemple et la piscine elle
est à
une demi-heure de marche avant j'y
allais en voiture mais maintenant j'y
vais à pied
si on regarde maintenant un peu plus
près de l'individu si on regarde son
salaire le salaire lui permet d'acquérir
des biens des services on va donc
essayer de regarder le pouvoir d'achat
du salaire on va le traduire en nombre
en bien et services qu'une unité de
salaire permet d'acquérir vous voyez
donc pour le salaire il y a deux
éléments à prendre en compte le salaire
lui-même qui peut évoluer et les prix
qui eux aussi peuvent évoluer quand les
prix évoluent seuls et quand ils
évoluent à la hausse qu'on a une
inflation d'avoir l'impression que on
est moins riche le pouvoir d'achat a
diminué quand les salaires augmentent et
augmentent plus que n’augmente les prix
là ce dégage un excédent le ménage
l'individu à l'impression d'être un peu
plus riche il en a plus pour son argent
il y a donc un gain de pouvoir d'achat
quand on dit tout augmente il s'agit
d'augmentation de l'augmentation des
prix il s'agit de l'inflation on ne peut
parler d'inflation que dès lors qu'on
observe une augmentation des prix mais
une augmentation
général et durable des prix elle va
impacter ce que l'on appelle le pouvoir
d'achat de la monnaie certains
économistes considèrent que l'inflation
est un phénomène monétaire dès lors
qu'on observe que le volume de monnaie
qui circule dans l'économie est déphasé
par rapport aux richesses et aux valeurs
qui sont créées dans l'économie et bien
inévitablement apparaît l'inflation
lorsqu'on commence à manger une tablette
de chocolat les premiers effets sont
appréciables on aime le chocolat mais
arrivé à la fin de la tablette c'est
beaucoup moins agréable la crise de foi
vous guette lorsqu'on met de la monnaie
dans l'économie lorsqu'on déverse la
monnaie dans l'économie ce sont les
premiers effets bénéfiques qui
apparaissent en premier les effets
secondaires négatifs apparaissent plus
tard et malheureusement ils apparaissent
parfois trop tard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]